alright guys I've got Austin here super
excited about this conversation we got a
lot to cover everything education so
before we get started I don't think I
actually don't even know what your
background is pre lambda sure yeah I
grew up in Utah did a bunch of crazy
stuff when I was younger ended up
working in wait hold on back like crazy
so so I'm Mormon so I served a mission
in eastern Ukraine came back dropped out
of school went to China Vagabond around
China where my home base was Shanghai
but I I literally didn't live anywhere I
just kind of had a suitcase and went
wherever hostels are super cheap there
so I just jump on a train yeah then went
back to to Utah decided to get into tech
somehow had had no money had no skills
just jumped in a Honda Civic and drove
out to Palo Alto and lived in my car for
a while well got things off the ground
and so what were you doing in China um I
mean this was like 2011 if you remember
at the time China was the thing yeah
everybody was always talking about China
I've been selling on stuff on eBay and
importing stuff on a small scale so I
was just interested in import/export
wanted to figure out what was going on
basically so yeah just decided to go out
and see what was happening decided that
import/export wasn't for me it's highly
regulated it's just it's a nasty space
it's full of antiquated stuff and now
flex port is taking it on bless their
hearts but yeah I really just decided to
double down on tech when I was out there
and yep yeah alright so you come back
drugged to Palo Alto living in your car
yep alright so one thing I always I mean
are you sleep in a front seat passenger
seat back seat yeah so you lay the the
passenger seat and the back seat down
feet in the trunk
unlike the passenger seat twin air
mattress halfway blown up it kind of
like covers up the the gaps I'm like a
like a sweetened there oh it was swanky
yeah alright so it in Soho G Civic while
you're while you're sleeping in the car
hanging out Palo Alto what a interests
kind of focus what what are you doing
yes so at that time I was working on a
company called grass wire basically
trying to crowdsource fact-checking of
the news it worked
so we ended up getting you know half
million dollars in VC and running it for
a year and a half it worked we got like
half a million visitors a month at its
peak but it's still there was no real
good way to monetize the news at that
time if it were today you would have put
a coin on it and done some crypto stuff
somehow gonna put a coin on it put a
coin on it I like that yeah kind of
steam it style stuff would have worked
but there was no way to incentivize
anything there's no way to monetize
other than generic ads was just a
nightmare also the the term fake news
had not been coined right if we were
about a year later we would have you
been riding that fake news yeah yeah we
were too early so we we basically died
the December before Trump started coming
to power so to speak got it and really
that's you know the fake news thing was
really largely a reaction to Trump but
so bad timing yep okay so so go through
that and obviously you know Lauren a
bunch I'm sure that your company dies
what do you do yeah so it was not it was
not a good time for the company to die
we were my daughter sorry my wife was
like eight and a half months pregnant
let's see we yes so we were we were
remote so I was living in the middle of
nowhere in Utah by my in-laws farm and
yeah so you got a house of this
I know we were still renting we're like
$120,000 for a house that doesn't smell
like but you're living in a house yeah
yeah
no car no field no yeah there's there's
never been to Utah so there's no such
yeah like a three-bedroom at the time
was like 120 K you could rent it for
like 600 bucks a month so there's no
point yeah yeah so company goes under
I'm like oh shoot go burn through all of
our savings paying off contractors and
making employees whole and all that
stuff and then our daughter ends up in
the NICU for a long time so we're like
brokers and broke no job living in the
middle of nowhere there's no tech
anything just farms in the community
college so I decided to write a book
about growth which is the stuff that I
had learned in the past couple years
sold that it did really well and then
that started kind of circulating in
Silicon Valley a company called lend up
in San Francisco saw it and reached out
and said hey can we have you join our
growth team and I said yes so ended up
in San Francisco got it and just overall
how to grow a tech company acquire users
yep user acquisition and the idea was
how to go from zero to a thousand users
for free you know kind of cheap gorilla
growth hacky stuff but very tutorial
like so it takes you through okay you
have this company here's how you figure
out which channel to use here's how you
figure out okay let's take Instagram
here's how you can win on Instagram
step-by-step literally just do this
stuff and it'll work here's how you went
on Twitter or step by step step by step
and it'll work and yeah so I I kind of
sold it as like a tutorial more so than
a generic marketing book and yep it did
well sold quarter-million dollars of it
was all self-published so you just
basically keep that what and that got us
out of the red yeah love that love that
alright so you get to wind up in San
Francisco working on the growth there
mhm what made you leave
yes left to start lambda basically you
know coming from a rural area to San
Francisco you just see the the huge
discrepancy in opportunity so you know
in the town I was from the median income
is like 30k and so I'd talk to people
and say hey there you know code school's
out there in 10th out you know ten
thousand dollars to go to a code school
like in San Francisco that's a referral
bonus that's that's nothing you know but
there's just no possible way those
people could move to San Francisco and
go to code school and not go broke all
at the same time so the original idea
was just hey let's take a code school
let's put it online so that it's more
accessible let's make it cheap since we
don't have physical buildings we can
drive the cost down the hole I mean just
classic hey let's put this on the
Internet
kind of thing yeah and yes started that
as kind of a side project while it lend
up and did you know we would get these
huge free classes to kind of promote it
so we'd have 7,000 people in this free
class and then we would convince a few
of them to pay us ten grand and that was
enough to quit our jobs and go full-time
and what they're doing is so free class
go in it's all online they're sitting at
home they're taking like a daily course
they're doing they you know kind of once
a week how does that work yes so the
free course is basically every night
Monday through Thursday for a few hours
you know we're introducing a topic
you're working on some stuff you have a
review obviously you can only do that so
much when there are 7,000 people so it's
a little bit different of a structure
there but it was basically hey let's
teach you how to program you know up to
a certain point for free and then if you
like it you can pay ten thousand dollars
and and do the rest well you know
training for three months kind of a
standard code school model we weren't
that creative in the beginning and that
that was really all it was to get off
the ground
we're just saying hey let's take you
know code schools exist let's put them
online and make it not suck that was in
entirety of the vision and is this one
of the schools when you first started
where you were recording a video or is
it one where you're building like
modules and people could go in and
actually
type so not either not either of those
things actually so so we felt and still
feel that it was very important to have
it be live so it's like live stream and
then you'll have group working sessions
where you're all working on the same
code base at the same time or you know
individual coding sessions and that's
true to this day it's still live and
interactive it's it's not exactly like a
classroom environment because we try to
make it better being online but no
different than you know showing up at a
class and having an instructor walk
through stuff with you and so as you're
doing this you realize hey we can get
you know thousands to sign up for a free
class pay attention we can convince some
subset of them to pay us you know real
money and you leave and it's just you
you've got a co-founder a team kind of
what was those really days
yeah it just me and my co-founder he was
basically teaching 9:00 a.m. to 9:00
p.m. and I was basically trying to get
butts in seats 9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m.
and as a part of that we started
emailing you know the thousands of
people that have signed up for the free
class like hey why don't why don't you
pay ten thousand dollars to the school
you've never heard of and like join us
and every single time the response was
you know hey I don't have the money B I
can probably get the money but that's
just way too much risk what if it
doesn't work on the other side I just
blew ten grand and frankly that's
deserved in the code boot camp space
there's a lot of bad product out there a
lot of really bad schools frankly so I
can't fault anybody for that and so we
we had like for our second cohort we had
one empty seat and we basically emailed
everybody and said hey we have you know
one seat left if you'll pay us a
thousand dollars up front that you can
pay us the other you know we'll add on a
finance charge so pay us ten thousand
dollars after you get hired same course
and we had like 200 applications come in
and that's when we realized okay there
there is something to the idea of
de-risking it for the student and if we
can do that then we can we can fix all
this other stuff that we've wanted to do
like we felt like three months wasn't
really long
to get you from where you needed to be
or from where you are to where you need
to be as a software engineer to get
hired but if you don't you know if
you're not charging ten thousand dollars
and you have to charge $20,000 how many
people are gonna charge you 20 if it's
hard to get them to pay you ten so from
that we basically moved to a model where
it was hey you can either pay us twenty
thousand dollars up front or you can
just pay you know then we started
delving into an income share agreement
where you don't pay us anything until
you get a job and then you'll will do an
income chair for a couple years if and
only if you get a job and we got a
couple people to pay upfront and that
funded the rest of the class and then we
when we announced that we had thousands
of applications coming in on the firaon
the free upfront with the income share
on the back end yep got it and so what
is the model today so the model today is
basically that it's completely free
until you get a job that pays more than
50k a year in the field that you study
otherwise you never pay anything if you
do get that job we share so you pay a
seventeen percent of your income for two
years capped at a total possible of 30k
so if your income is below 50k you pay
zero if it's above 90 K you pay 30k if
it's somewhere in between there it's a
percentage of income you pay it off over
two years and you're done got it that um
definitely D risks for somebody who
wants to learn and say I'm gonna bet on
myself okay some degree but either one
doesn't the money or two you know that
the price is the hurdle what has been
the success rate on the back end um yeah
so our first cohort eighty-three percent
of the students were hired and making
more than 50k Wow
it it stayed right about that level it's
incredibly big difficult to get to the
head frankly but but yeah it's it's
working mm-hmm and so let's talk about
the education kind of in the traditional
world right so what's the issue there
right why is there so much demand for
what you're doing
there are a couple main factors that I
mean so right now if you are living in
middle America and you want to change a
career there are two huge problems the
first is that it will take you probably
four years you have to go get a
university degree in two years it's
going to be studying Shakespeare and the
you know liberal arts which I have no
problem with but not an efficient way to
switch careers and the second is it it's
really freaking expensive it's gone up
like two thousand percent in the last
ten years alone the average you know
person that gets a degree you're looking
at 100 hundred fifty K in debt that's
just too much to handle right that's you
know I always think about it from a risk
perspective that is a whole lot of risk
to take on hoping that this new career
change pays off for you so you know the
opportunity cost of your time and the
cost cost of the tuition and living
expenses for four years it's just
astronomical so we basically we D risk
the education by making it free upfront
and then yeah we the the other aspect of
that is a university isn't really built
to get you a job that's kind of a debut
that as a side effect of what they do
but they're not like gunning for that
for us that's all we care about and you
you don't come to us if you don't want a
job but you do come to us and we will do
everything we possibly can to help you
get a job or we don't get paid and the
incentives really really matter how do
you drive that high like success rate
and getting the job yeah I mean the
first thing is picking qualified
students that show us that they're
capable the second thing is picking a
job market where there is high demand
and then third is just we know that we
have to make you the best engineer you
possibly can be and if you're a really
solid software engineer and you're
looking for a job you will find one it's
it's just a matter of do you have enough
time and gumption to look
which is a problem we run into in some
of the lower income backgrounds I just
don't have the day graduation hits
they're out of money and that's a
problem we we have to deal with but but
generally speaking it just works right
the the promise of hey you can learn
this skill and people will pay you to
perform that skill
it just it works it always has and you
don't have to believe us because you
know otherwise you won't pay us anything
yep that makes sense what do you think
about the traditional world there's an
argument that I recently it was an op-ed
that I read that said you know a place
like Harvard for example has such a
large endowment that they should lose
their their education status their
school status because it's basically
like a financial institution with a
school attached to it right freezing tax
benefits I don't even you know I have no
opinion Jerry disagree but how does that
type of endowment model and kind of the
the large financial focus for some of
these institutions play into you know
how much they charge how the the kind of
the overall system works you know
Harvard could
Harvard could make their tuition zero
and relative to the size of their
endowment it wouldn't move the needle
that much right it just they may as well
take 40 KMS tur from rich people because
that's what a lot of their student body
is anyway I think the goal of Harvard
and the goal of lambda school are just
very very different I had a conversation
recently with someone who did who does
the the interviews for Harvard and in
their handbook they say you know Harvard
you know we're trying to find the next
Michelangelo we're not trying to create
the meta cheese for the people that
funded Michelangelo so there's kind of a
a social element there or social class
statement that you know we don't want to
train the merchants money-making class
we want to train something higher
something more enlightened so and that's
just not our goal right well we'll
create as many Medicis as we possibly
can yep and we want to take people that
aren't meta cheese and make them Medicis
and then they can fund the
Michelangelo's later so I think just
fundamentally the you know our goal
isn't necessarily to create you know
Nobel Prize winners and we're not it's
just a very very different
organizational structure and goal
absolutely
what is the like biggest problem as
people go through the program that you
see if some is not technical becoming
technical and gaining that skill set
like what are those challenges that you
guys really work with people to kind of
you know smoother over the transition
yeah I think the first and foremost
people I don't know if they have
forgotten how to learn or if they've
never learned how to learn but so many
people come into lamb to school and
they're like okay you know what you know
what is required what's gonna be on the
test what do I have to do to check all
the boxes so that I can signal to to
whomever that I know this stuff and that
just doesn't that fundamentally does not
work in software engineering and
software engineering you have to be able
to approach something you've never seen
before
understand how to decompose that
understand what works what doesn't work
what will be optimal what will be
suboptimal make trade-offs and then
solve the problem and that is very very
different than the way the educational
system has traditionally been run so we
have to kind of beat that out of people
we have to beat out of them the idea
that you show up you check boxes and
you're done or you know you jump through
various hoops and that shows everybody
that you can do all the stuff that you
need to do you just can't do that as a
software engineer
so we basically spend the first month
trying to create a new system of
incentives and motivation that are you
know you we need two people to learn how
to learn
once that clicks four people and you can
it's almost visible then then they're
set then they're off to the races and
they can do anything and everything and
we don't have to worry about them
anymore yeah it's awesome and do you
find that once they get over that hump
of you know here's how to learn again
the the information that they acquire
like there's an acceleration oh
absolutely that even continues like post
the program into their job yeah I mean
the the the cool thing is at the end of
lambda school not only can you do the
stuff that we've taught you how to do
but when you see something that you've
never approached before yeah a good
student will say to themselves oh I know
how to learn that I've never touched it
before but like let's dive in let's look
at the documentation let's figure it out
I think that that's an acquired skill
for most people at least in the u.s.
today just that even the notion that you
can see something that you know nothing
about and you can figure it out is very
foreign to most people no you know most
people come to us because they don't
understand that that's possible and we
have to teach them to do that
well and not only is it how to do it but
it's the desire we want to learn
something new right why don't we see
something that they don't understand and
they just walk away yeah I mean I the
the funny thing is I look back you
when I was younger and I see that in
myself like there there were so many
times when I would see something and I'd
be like I can't figure out how to do
that because I'm not I'm not a softer
edge I've never been trained to do that
and it was once I really started to say
okay you know what I'm just gonna do
whatever I want and I'll you know figure
it out as I go which by the way that
kind of clicked for me when I was living
in Ukraine learning to speak Russian and
just like yeah I don't I don't know how
to speak Russian but I'm gonna try with
this guy you know and that that really
matters so now it's you know I'm dealing
a lot with I mean as a CEO of a rapidly
growing company everything that I'm
dealing with I've never touched before
never imagined before but it's not that
intimidating it's just I know there's a
learning curve I know I have to pick
stuff up as I go I'm not a finance guy
but I had had to learn finance one of
you know structuring all this stuff had
to learn how to manage how to organize a
company all that stuff but you can do it
and they're there materials out there
there are resources there are people and
you can just figure stuff out absolutely
how many people have gone through the
program so we've had 150 graduates and
then 700 are concurrently enrolled got
it what what are some of the things
you've learned from you know because
there's probably thousands of
applications you've got hundreds now who
have either gone through or going
through what are the biggest things
you've learned about people and and kind
of going through this transition yeah I
think the first is you assume that
everybody has the same like requirements
and needs that you do you just figure
that oh this is what I needed so
everybody else is the same way the I
mean instructional design is not I mean
there are a lot of code schools it's
like yeah we don't need to worry about
that stuff it'll just you know we're
engineers we'll figure it out we can
teach but a good really good
instructional designer that's done that
for 10 15 years knows how to take all
these different things into
consideration when they're building a
curriculum so that it works for
people from all sorts of different
backgrounds and stress levels and all
sorts of stuff so we definitely
underestimated the difficulty in
creating a really good curriculum and
then the other thing is just the and
this is constantly a learning battle
because a lot of our students come from
very low-income backgrounds they're very
stressed financially from day one
creating an environment where somebody
that's already that already has stress
at level nine based on their normal life
circumstances getting them to learn
something that's incredibly difficult is
it's hard and we have to to build in
support for that kind of thing
sometimes that's financial support we
can only do that so much a lot of the
time it's just emotional support it's
just you know sometimes people just need
somebody to talk to and that's that's
that's another thing we definitely
underestimated got it and then what are
the challenges that you guys have gone
through that you guys have already
overcome right so as you started
building this it sounds like there was
you know people who came in yet to learn
a lot about who are these people
what are they kind of going through
outside of the school what are their
goals how do we actually get them into
jobs and you know kind of there's the
nitty-gritty blocking and tackling of
building a company but are there
specific challenges that stick out to
you in terms of you know they hit you
really hard and and forced you to kind
of wake up and get through them yeah so
if you look at lambda school is kind of
a traditional you know what are all the
risks that are involved in this startup
and let's start peeling them away it
basically starts out with can you get
people who haven't paid anything upfront
to finish a six-month program so really
really focusing on the persistence of
somebody's desire to finish yeah I mean
when we started everyone was like you
guys are gonna get killed because
students have no skin in the game you
guys took on all the risk what you know
if they just shut a laptop and walk away
what happens and they're right right
like
we have to find people that are
dedicated and motivated and then the
course has to be so good that there's
never a point where they're just like
you know what to hell with this how do
you screen for the dedication and
motivation so now we you know it in the
beginning we would try stuff like hey
let's try this logic challenge and if
you can figure you know if you can think
analytically enough to get through this
challenge then we'll accept you now we
actually require all the students to go
through a class before they start and we
monitor people when they're in that
class and see how well you do in that
kind of trial environment so we call it
tryouts and we accept people based on
how well they're able to be dedicated
and you know finish stuff and all that
so that's something and kind of put in
sweat equity as opposed to a cache and
that's the skin of the game is that you
got to get to the tryout and if you're
good enough to get to the tryout then
you're welcome if not then see you later
yep yeah that's exactly right and you
would be shocked at how many people who
are incredibly talented just don't have
they won't show up every day yeah and
that's I can I can take somebody that
will show up every day and work hard and
I can teach them how to code if you're
an already mediocre coder and you still
won't show up every day I can't help you
so that's yeah I think what we really
learned was the the grit level of a
student is the most important factor
what um
is it as an all day every day
or is it a night class how do you offer
students when you say show up every day
all right what is the ask of them on a
daily basis yeah so it's it's for the
full time class it's 8:00 a.m. to 5:00
p.m. your button seat so at 8:00 a.m. to
5:00 p.m. Pacific so you know different
time zones are different Monday through
Friday for seven and a half months for
the part time class it's 6 p.m. to 9
p.m. Pacific which is you know 9 p.m. to
midnight Monday through Thursday and
then 3 hours on Saturday for a year so
basically you can either say I'm going
full-time I'm not going to have a job
for seven and a half months or I'm going
to keep my job and I'm not going to have
a life for a year and there's just
there's simply no way around that right
you have to be able to put in the hours
or there there's nothing we can do to
help you mm-hmm what's the number one
reason people quit is just the rest of
their life like everything else kind of
just takes over yeah by far you have a
spouse supporting you and then the
spouse loses a job you have a death in
the family sometimes it's like we have a
lot of students in the southeast and
when hurricanes hit yeah it's so
frustrating
so shark attacks just all kinda like
it's not going yeah I mean when you know
we have 700 students enrolled right now
at that kind of scale like something
crazy is gonna happen to somebody it's
just it's just going to happen so
they're you know that just comes with
the territory and we have to build it
into our model and work with people we
had a student that was in on vacation in
Costa Rica
I think either Costa Rica Puerto Rico
one of one of the two got mugs got
everything stolen like pack couldn't you
know barely made his way home so he you
know we didn't know what happened to him
he just didn't log on and then three
weeks later he shows up and says hey I
got I got mugged and it took me three
weeks to get back home
Wow and you know so we can accommodate
stuff like that but stuff happens yeah
yeah
and this is the classes are all in
English all in English no the languages
yet nope we not yet yeah one day
yep and then what are you teaching
rights are you teaching one single
language
are you teaching multiple languages and
I as a student could pick walk me
through kind of you know some of the
content itself yeah so we separated into
different tracks the the full stack web
development track will teach JavaScript
which is you know react node we used to
teach [ __ ] we recently removed [ __ ]
and replaced it with relational
databases equal Postgres stuff like that
that's kind of
fifteen weeks is full-stack traditional
javascript stack web development then we
have ten weeks of computer science that
is based in C and Python so Python and
Django just because we want you to have
exposure to a new language will do a lot
of the data structures and algorithms
training in Python first of all because
it's a different language but second of
all it's probably a better language than
JavaScript I should be careful saying
that but um it doesn't have the same
side effects that JavaScript has and
this little better to reason with when
it comes to data structures and
algorithms and then C because C doesn't
let you abstract away all the hard stuff
and you have to deal with the lower
level so when we're talking about
systems and architecture and operating
systems we use C for that and then we
have a five-week apprenticeship that we
call lambda labs it's kind of a
simulated dev shop environment you can
use new languages so we have students
build stuff in react native or Ruby and
rails or whatever that you know you can
kind of choose choose your own path we
also have a program that's a little bit
different for the full stack web
development called lambda custom and
that is when an employer comes to us and
says hey I want to hire 10 phoenix any
lecture engineers will basically swap
out the traditional curriculum for
something that includes phoenix and the
elixir but they have to be willing to
guarantee you they'll hire 10 students
for it to be worth our time doing that
got it then we have other tracks we have
iOS we have Android we have UX design we
have data science and those you know
follow a similar pattern but you'd have
to map what I just said on on to those
different that makes sense what about
blockchain interests right so obviously
most of the people listening our
supersuit blockchain crypto etc our
students aware of it are they interested
in it are they looking for jobs in the
industry what would have you seen so far
yeah a lot of students come in or not I
don't know if I should say a lot but
there are definitely some students that
come in
interested in crypto and we have some
some side stuff that we send them
through so they actually understand that
the cryptography aspect of crypto not
just here's how the blockchain works but
you know keys all that stuff yeah we
have a few students that are hired as
blockchain developers it's not a
majority of the students but those
students are really well paid there's a
pretty big shortage of blockchain
engineers we say pretty well play what
do you think average all right
I shouldn't our average is ridiculous
our average for blockchain based
engineer is like in the hundred ninety K
range 190,000 I mean you know that like
20 blockchain engineers just went to
their boss and said hey I need a raise
yeah I again I'm not saying that's
average but that's what our average has
been I I would imagine that it will net
out to being its kind of software
engineering salaries plus 20 percent you
know bonus for understanding how crypto
works yep and then do you see any
difference between the people who come
in that are interested in crypto versus
not in you know going through the
program or kind of the skills that
they're better at or worse at because it
sounds like they're stuffing on the back
end there's a difference in kind of
maybe salary but anything in the middle
of the program um I think it's just a
different like focus area for them so
there's a lot of people that are kind of
you know hey bitcoin is cool and I have
a coin base account and then once they
learn to become a software engineer then
they and once they learned to learn like
we talked about then they start to
actually delve into how does the
blockchain actually work what is this
what is what is a ledger you know how
what it what are we actually talking
about when we're talking about moving
crypto from point A to point B what you
know so that that's really cool to see
that they there's a certain point where
it moves from hey crypto is this
abstract thing and they're you know
prices go up and down to
let's understand the tech under the hood
let's read what Satoshi wrote let's
understand you know all that stuff and I
think there are surprisingly few people
in the crypto community that understand
all of that fully there are a lot of
people that are trusting other people
when they say crypto is secure crypto is
you know a private method of transaction
crypto is you know if you you could
probably list off a bunch of different
things more than I could off the top of
my head and people get that conceptually
but when you understand the tech when
you understand cryptography when you
understand how mining actually works
instead of yeah I just I'm just gonna
buy a GPU rig and plug it into something
it's pretty cool to see yeah absolutely
what um what do you guys need the most
help with right so people who are
listening what can they do to make you
guys more successful um the first thing
is stop lumping in lambda school with
other code boot camps that suck when
you're hiring engineers that's probably
our biggest battle is people look at us
and they say oh yeah I've I hired
somebody from an 8-week code boot camp
once and they didn't perform very well
of course they didn't yep um how do you
get over that right now all right say
hey right now eight weeks it how's the
seven and a half months yeah right now
it's like so we have a lot of companies
that come to us or we come to them we
have a biz dev team there's constantly
trying to create those relationships and
they're like yeah you know we're looking
for someone with a CS degree that writes
Java and we're always like okay just
interview one just try it and we've had
multiple companies that you know first
of all they hire that person they pay
them 110 K and then they come back to us
and we literally have companies coming
to us now saying can you send us 50 more
can we you know wow what can we do to
you know we need to hire 200 engineers
next year we want to make 150 of them
lambda grads get me more of that so
there's some some element of just
you know you they need to try and
interview and hire the right person and
then then they get it
so we've have companies now that have
hired seven or eight students we've
we've only had graduates for six months
right yep so that that's really how we
win in the long run it's just by better
product yeah what so I definitely agree
with that what is your incentive if I'm
a student and based on the way that I
understand the the pricing mechanism
right basically as soon as I get paid
more than ninety thousand dollars you're
kind of capped out right so what is the
school's incentive to help me go from
110 130 to 150 let's say on that salary
is it just the better that I leave with
a great experience great job etc I
become an ambassador for lambda or how
do you think about that yeah so we
intentionally capped how much we take
from an income share just because I mean
if you're making 80k and you paste back
you know 27 K that's a pretty fair trade
if you start to make 150 K and all the
sudden you're paying us like 60 K then
that feels I mean obviously incentives
are still aligned but it starts to feel
a little bit shady at that point so we
just put a hard cap on it that said you
know we want you to be as successful as
we possibly can be we do report averages
we do report
you know incomes I love it when our
students get hired for 110 even though
that doesn't change our income level at
all from when you're getting paid 90 I
mean the truth is we do get it a little
bit faster still because they'll you
know they're still paying the 17%
they'll hit their cap earlier so that's
a small bonus but I mean really the long
term in the long run the way lambda wins
is if we have thousands of successful
students out there that employers trust
and you know later on in lambdas
lifecycle will start to have you know
more products for hey you want to hire
software engineer that has two or three
years of experience now we have
thousands of software engineers with two
or three years of experience itself a
relationship with us there all sorts of
I mean that our relationship with the
student is usually really really strong
they they're grateful they are they want
to give back to the community in some
way so we're just trying to foster that
as much as we can
absolutely that makes sense all right so
I got two questions for you and then
we'll wrap it up but if you could change
anything about the current education
system what would you change I would oh
man they're like any things the first is
you have to realize the education system
is 100% built around title for funding
okay so so title for funding is
basically Pell grants federally
subsidized student loans every
University every college is 100% built
to pull money out from that pool or
they're dead that is what education is
built around entirely to be able to
receive title for funding you have to
become accredited which means you have
to go through an accrediting body
recognized by the you know US Department
of Education and there are a couple ways
you can do that but basically those are
the people that are making the rules for
the entire educational you know for all
of higher ed across the u.s. because
everyone is relying on title for funding
those rules are insane when we're we
were looking at it you have to have for
most programs you have to have two years
of general studies which may or may not
make sense depending on what you're
going into you have to have your
curriculum approved by certain people
which makes it really difficult to adapt
and change curriculum which in computer
science world is just a recipe for
disaster
um you have to have a librarian on staff
full-time so even if you're in online
school it doesn't actually have a
librarian you have to have somebody with
a master's degree in librarian studies
on your staff that's wild so it's it's
just it's literally if you took 50 PhDs
at them down in a room and said what do
you think the requirement should be for
education in the United States
that's literally what is happening and
they can write the rules for everybody
and the only way you can break away from
that is if you're not taking federal
funding and there's a rule called the
90/10 rule which is that if you're a
for-profit college you can only take 90
percent of your income or revenue from
federal funds and that's a huge problem
is people are trying to stay below that
90 percent so it like that gives you a
sense of how reliant everybody is on on
student loans basically or Pell grants
and whatever else if you made if you
said people can now bankrupt their way
out of student loans like you can't
declare bankruptcy on student loans are
there forever
that would Rock the education system if
you said schools have to you know less
than 50 percent of your students can
default on their student loans that
would Rock the education system which is
crazy fifty percent it's a huge huge
default rate especially when you're
talking about something that you can't
bankrupt your way out of and is with you
forever so I think the big problem is
that there's just no like the blind are
leading the blind and there's nobody
that can raise their hand and stop
anything so it's just this incestuous
you know the the PhD is right the rules
for how accreditation is granted as soon
as accreditation is there you have
unlimited backing from Uncle Sam so you
can charge whatever you want it all ends
up on the students back the student ends
up screwed but you don't care because I
got mine it's just a very very broken
system across the board absolutely and I
think we're starting to see the the
impact
of the debt that we're putting on all of
these these students is pretty uh pretty
misunderstood I think years ago and now
is uh it's quite sad frankly yeah I mean
when I went to college you know most of
my high school buddies came from lower
middle class environments and nobody
told us anything about student loans
ever it was all just go to the best
school you possibly can study something
you love and if you get a degree it'll
all work out on the other side and
that's just fundamentally not true
especially in this day and age now you
know a lot of people have degrees and
they're I wish I could remember the the
number there's something like 5,000
people in the US with PhDs that work as
janitors it's just that's a time it's a
whole lot yeah it's the expectations of
the students and society are just
completely misaligned with the
expectations of the university and
frankly the results so you know net-net
you still make more money if you have a
bachelor's degree than if you don't
because of course if you take all of the
smart people in society and you have
them get a bachelor's degree by
definition they're going to you know it
will bear out in the stats but we've
translated that into everybody needs a
bachelor's degree and if you don't get
one you're screwed and pay whatever it
takes because that's the only way to
make it and that's you know coupling
that with end will give you unlimited
money to do that because we think it's
really important and we're not paying
attention to what happens on the other
side it's just a recipe for disaster and
we're seeing that now absolutely all
right
so ask one question to end it and then
I'll let you ask me one question before
we're all right you gotta admit that
aliens exist somewhere in the solar
system galaxies etc do we think that
aliens have pets
yeah so are there alien animals there's
a paradox I'm trying to remember what
it's called but this is not what you
asked necessarily but aliens so far as
we know have not made contact with us
right so either they don't know we exist
they're not advanced enough to make
contact with us or they have
conscientiously decided that it's just
better off to let those humans do their
own thing and leave them alone my word
like too stupid for them yeah I don't
know like yeah I yeah you could be like
yeah let's just not disturb their
natural environment let's let them burn
it to the ground on their own well cuz
we always think about like we haven't
found the aliens right but what if they
know that we exist and and we don't know
that they exist yeah it's I mean it has
to be one of those three things by
definition right either they don't exist
or we're not one or the other isn't
advanced enough to make contact with the
other or they're consciously deciding
not to make contact with us and they
could I think the latter is pretty
unlikely like I think if they could make
contact you at least try to say like hey
what's up let's you know maybe there's
something like a like a you up text that
to a head maybe there's some information
sharing that could happen somewhere I'm
I'm sure if you you know if you create
one simulated environment and then
another one like they'll both evolve in
different ways and I mean you don't get
it you don't get a chance to say let's
let's try all of humanity over again and
see what happens this time that'd be
that'd be cool you know um so I'm gonna
say that if there are aliens out there
they're not advanced enough to make
contact with us and if you look at let's
see so how long was it from the time
that we domesticated animals until we
were a spacefaring civilization maybe
well it's less than a thousand years
right yeah I believe so so in the
expanse of time and space if we say you
know the earth is hundreds
millions of years old I'm gonna say it's
unlikely that they have reached the
point of domesticating animals yet
because if they would have then it's
pretty likely that they would be
progressing to the point where they
could make contact with us how's that
for an answer that's probably the most
thoughtful and normally people are just
like we are that we are the pets and we
are the animals but but not me I think
that's completely fair all right what uh
what question you want to ask me
let's ask you a hard one this always
scares me so much when people are like
oh let me ask you a question
crypto transaction volume slowly going
down y-yeah look I am a believer that it
will continue to go down so we're doing
this in October of 2018 right I think
that the beauty of a blockchain and
crypto in general is security right and
trust and so like I usually draw this
spectrum for people on the left side of
the spectrum you have security on the
right side you have like you know
innovation and like all the shiny stuff
Bitcoin specifically is like as far left
on that spectrum as you can get in terms
of securities that number one thing
right so really really slow you know low
transaction volumes because of the
slowness it just doesn't really work
today as a medium of exchange for a
whole host of reasons yeah what we've
seen is a bunch of people trying to push
blockchain technology and crypto to the
right of that spectrum I say start doing
all sorts of things around speeding up
transactions so the on the left side of
the spectrum you have store value on the
right side you have means of exchange
not necessarily right so I think that it
I think of it I'll call it replacing
credit cards on the right side maybe so
it for payments specifically yes right I
think that I just look at payment or
non-payment blockchains and in crypto
you know projects companies that are all
on this spectrum of like are you
optimizing for security or you
optimizing for you know speed innovation
and kind of all the shiny stuff sure to
me we actually because we're all like to
smart firown' good
meaning people in technology like we
keep pushing farther and farther to the
right of that spectrum and we want all
the innovation the speed and all that
stuff and we should do that right that
that is where like the R&D and the
innovation accessions gonna happen but I
think that I'm probably much more of a
Bitcoin maximalist than most in this
idea of like the security and the trust
of the chain and the technology is the
core component sure and so while people
are doing all that innovation and doing
all those crazy stuff like people the
Bitcoin developers are gonna keep adding
that to the Bitcoin chain right so smart
contracts and all stuff so when we look
at transaction volumes for example well
the most adopted chain which is Bitcoin
and the most secure chain is also a slow
chain because of the optimization for
security sure so you can make the
argument that if you're calling it a
store of value
you don't look at like the transaction
volume of gold to determine the value of
gold right it's it's so that's
definitely just the wrong measure yes so
that's one way to do it I think that
what becomes interesting though is is
there a world where as we really
solidify the security the distributed
nature of of the technology can we
actually improve transaction volume the
speeds and all this stuff and so that's
not gonna happen
in the first 10 years sure right like so
we're not at Bitcoin 0.1 yet don't try
to do Bitcoin 2.0 don't try to don't try
to layer on speed and payments because
we're still figuring out the very very
fundamentals of yeah well I got like
we're at like of the block let's say
we're at Bitcoin you know zero point
five right and people aren't even at 2.0
people are like you know there's some
people have launched like four you know
improved bitcoins already lately how are
you doing number four all right here we
haven't figured out like the original
Bitcoin and so I think that the saying
of like the people with the longest time
horizons have an advantage here is
definitely applicable and you know we're
building a technology that if it can
actually you know glimmer on a third of
the promise right so thinking has a take
over the money supply doesn't have to
you know do all stuff if it just
delivers on a third of what the promise
is it's probably one of the most
important technologies of our lifetime
right and so that should be you know
clearly with care security is everything
well so if there was a security issue of
the Bitcoin blockchain
right I would make the argument that
Bitcoin would become undoubtable yeah
right so if there's a fraudulent
transaction if there was some sort of
security breach and like a material way
what is the value of Bitcoin during zero
right yeah so I think that you know when
you look at you know what is the most
important core focus it is security and
so there's a saying in the military that
slow is smooth smooth is fast
right and so I think that that's kind of
what we're seeing with Bitcoin of like
it goes slow but it goes smoothly and
because it goes smoothly we're actually
making pretty fast progress sure right
because at any point if we try to speed
up and there's an issue you have you
lose all the momentum right and so I
think we've seen that with some of the
alt coins and so to answer your question
like I'm not worried about the
transaction volumes because I don't
think that's like that's not the right
metric yeah I don't think it's according
to focus on and my hope though is that
over time it will improve after we
figured out kind of that foundational
security yeah that's fair yeah fair
awesome and I really appreciate you
coming I'm a huge fan of what you guys
are doing but how can people find out
more apply to to to come to a class yeah
so we have free classes that start every
month you can try it out absolutely no
no cost lambda school comm la MBTA
school comm awesome well let's get some
more people in there we'll get some more
blockchain developers awesome love it we
need them all right thanks so much
Austin thank you
you